(audience applauding)
(bright music)
- We did it!
We made it through our first
week of this show together!
(audience applauding)
(screams)
I don't think I've ever had
this much fun in my entire life
and I hope that you have
enjoyed this week too.
That's the whole point of all of this.
Let's turn to our virtual
friends and family, our VFFs.
(audience applauding)
How fun is that?
Emily, can I ask you a question?
Who is your favorite guest this week?
- I loved her interview with Shirley's,
it was so natural and organic,
and part of a genuine
conversation, I loved it.
- Oh, I'm so happy to hear that.
It's so nice to hear feedback, you know,
it gives us a sense of
what people are liking
or connecting to, it's really important.
Thank you for sharing, I mean it.
You know what, spoiler alert!
All of the guests were my favorite.
(audience applauding)
Okay.
It's true.
I'm so excited for today's guest too.
Billy Porter is here and he is nominated
(audience applauding)
for another Emmy this weekend.
In fact, I even wore this outfit for him
because I mean, he is the king of style.
Also today, the mom
behind this viral photo
opens up about her son's struggle
with distance learning,
something a lot of us can relate to.
This photo went crazy and
we get to talk to her today.
But first let's get into some Drew's News.
(audience applauding)
(car brakes screeching)
(glass shattering)
(cat meowing)
(upbeat music)
Excuse me, sir! mom! Guy!
Tell me your story!
Mom, I asked you a question.
This is Drew's News!
This is Drew's News.
It's Drew's News!
(bright music)
(audience applauding)
(hands clapping)
Fun fact, the dog in the
Drew's News monologue opener,
that's Lucy, my dog.
Alright, now let's see
what made the papers.
Okay, first up the Deseret News
reports on a new study from Brigham young,
looking at why girls love
Disney princesses so much.
They surveyed a large group of girls
and found that they connected
to them for four reasons.
Okay, their virtues,
they're royalty, (sneers)
their aspirational lives, okay,
and their rebellious spirits.
Hm.
I can relate to that last one.
So can my daughter, Olive.
Trust me.
The thing about this, though,
that really speaks to me
is it reminds me of a
movie called "Ever After".
(audience applauds)
Thanks guys.
The reason "Ever After" changed my life
is because as a girl, we read fairytales
and we're a little conditioned
to wait to be rescued
and this film totally flipped
the script pun intended
on that for me.
It's like, we still want
love at the end of the day,
you still want the prince, you
still want all the romance,
but the point is to get yourself there.
And for me to have that
revelation in my early twenties,
that we don't wait to be
rescued, we rescue ourselves,
well, it changed the entire course
of the rest of my professional
and personal life.
And I just wanna thank Disney
because I think you've
really modernized fairytales
for young girls out there.
We no longer wait to be rescued.
We do want love and the
Prince at the end of the day,
don't get us wrong, but you've shown us
that we can dream big
princess and be capable
and we need stories that
remind us of just that.
So thank you.
(audience applauding)
(hands clapping)
So, okay.
In transition, our next story requires you
to loosen that belt buckle
cause it's some time for food news.
(audience applauding)
Okay.
This story totally spoke to me
because my girls gets
so excited when I say,
"We're going to the gas station."
It's kind of their favorite place to eat.
It's true, come on, there's
so many treats and snacks,
they love it.
So check this out, girls.
7-11 is getting in on the action
with the new line of
Autumnal Sandwich Cookies.
They've got pumpkin spice,
they've got salted caramel,
they've even got ye old candy corn.
(audience laughing)
All sold by the sleeve, and
I've got some right here.
(paper rustling)
That's right.
Apparently this is called the sleeve.
I just learned that too.
All right, let's taste
test the candy corn,
ye old candy corn.
Oh hey, VFFs?
Nathan, Ashley, you want to
get it on, on the action?
I heard you ran out to
7-11 and picked some up
to taste test with me.
- Hi Drew!
Yeah, we just got back.
We got some candy corn,
we can't wait to try it.
- And also pumpkin spice.
- Cheers, cookie cheers.
What do you guys think?
- Not bad.
- Yeah, I think they taste
pretty much exactly like candy corn,
maybe a little bit
sweeter, but they're great.
- I definitely taste the
pumpkin, not as much spice,
but it's good.
- I'm gonna say winner
winner chicken dinner.
I'm in and thank you, Nathan and Ashley
for being culinary guinea pigs with me.
(hands clapping)
Okay.
Now it is time for our
Drew's News astrology report.
(upbeat music)
(hands clapping)
So, here to help us read the stars
is astrologer extraordinaire, Aliza Kelly.
(audience applauding)
(hands clapping)
Hi Aliza!
- Drew, thank you so much for
having me, congratulations.
- Thank you so much, I--
- [Eliza] This is so exciting.
- It is, it is.
- It's so exciting.
- And it's like first week, done, got it.
Okay, here we go.
And we get to go into the weekend with you
and I wanna ask September,
what's going on?
Well, you launched at the perfect time
because we are actually in a
transitional moment right now.
So on September 22nd, we
are beginning Libra season.
It's the autumn Equinox.
So we're moving into a
reflective, thoughtful energy.
We're gonna see a little less sun,
but this means that we're
gonna be our own sun.
We're going to generate our own radiance
and we're going to learn
to understand ourselves
from a different perspective.
- Aliza, can I ask you
what a birth chart is?
- It is basically a snapshot of the sky
at someone's or some
thing's exact time of birth.
So using the birth chart,
we could see the rising,
the sun and the moon,
and we can really understand
who that person is
or if it's an event, what that person
or what that event is all about.
- Well, speaking of birth charts,
I heard you maybe have a surprise for us?
- I do, I do.
(screaming)
Okay, so I know that
this is your launch week.
I know that you just
launched on September 14th.
So I decided to look at the astrology
for the Drew Barrymore show.
- It's like having a birth chart
for basically my third child.
- Yes.
- Okay, tell us what is it?
- So you have a beautiful third child.
The third child is a Libra rising.
So this is perfect, it's
beautiful, it's about balance,
it's about harmony, it's about symmetry
and it's also a very social energy.
So it's about sharing the stage.
It's about you giving
basically a space for others
to be able to share their stories too.
It's all about that scales of balance.
- Oh my gosh, that's exactly
what our mission is here.
- It's perfect.
- Okay, wait.
Okay, what about our rising sun?
- So the sun is a Virgo for
the Drew Barrymore show,
and what I really love about
this is that you are a Pisces.
- I am.
- And Virgo and Pisces
are opposite signs,
but opposite in astrology
is actually a very wonderful thing
because it means the goal is the same,
just different ways of getting there.
So you and the show are
basically have the same mission,
which is how can I make
the world a better place?
- And how about the moon?
(imitates wolf howl)
(Aliza laughing)
- Yes, so the moon is
also a very important part
of the astrology.
It is sort of what's
going on on the inside.
It is the emotional inner world
and in this case, it's really showing us
the backbone of the show and it's Leo,
which is all about
entertaining and theatricality
and passion and really having fun.
So at the end of the day,
we're going to find balance,
we're going to help people,
we're gonna use communication
and we're also gonna have a great time
and look fabulous while we're doing it.
So that's a pretty good
chart, I would say.
(audience applauding)
(Aliza laughing)
- Aliza!
- [Aliza] It's a good chart
- And you know what I did?
I hope it's okay not to
add more onto your plate,
but I asked my mom if she would give me
the exact time I was born, it's 11:51 AM
and I've never had my chart done.
Could I--
- You haven't?
- Ah ah.
- Oh my goodness, we have
to do this right now.
- Could I ask you to do my chart,
and we could come back on
the show and talk about it?
- It's a yes from me.
It's a big yes, right here.
- Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank
you I really appreciate it.
(bright music)